what are your thoughts right now
DeSantis Trump where are you at with
that has anything changed listen here's
what I say and you know I gotta people
sometimes knock me because you know my
whole thing I talk about mob stuff and I
think Michael don't get into politics
and what I try to tell people this is
not politics these are issues that are
affecting your life the way politicians
are dealing with it they're creating
these issues but these are issues that
are affecting you know our lives are
very live so I try to tell me it's not
politics I'm interested in the future of
this country and my kids my
grandchildren your this is issues that
we need to talk about so when when you
look at Biden in that regard
I just can't believe you know the damage
that he's done to this country and
continues
you know and look if he was a good
Democrat
hey great you know he's doing the right
thing so getting back to Trump and the
scientists I love DeSantis I I gotta say
I love what he's doing I love his
boldness I think all his moves were
right and when Trump was in office I
thought his policies were great his
policies I thought he didn't act
presidential in so many ways getting on
Twitter and doing things I really
believe Patrick and forget the
conspiracy theories about the you know
the the fraud and the in the uh the
election
if he would have a year before all of
this he would have said you know what
I'm not going to argue with Nancy Pelosi
I'm not going to do this I'm not going
to stoop to that level I'm worried about
the people in this country I'm going to
continue to do the right thing for the
country and and get rid of all that
other stuff that he did all that
pettiness all that divisiveness that's
what killed him I understand he's a New
Yorker he fights back in his defense
I've never seen anybody get attacked
like that every single day of his life
getting boom boom I've never seen
anything like it and you know to his
credit he stood up to it he didn't fold
and he didn't he didn't go into the
pressure but the way he reacted it was
so divisive and people have had enough
even now you know the one thing about
the him on the CNN deal he acted more
present he tried to stay on the issues I
said wow maybe maybe this you know the
light went off in his head maybe he's
starting to realize forget all this
other nonsense tell people what they
need to hear what they want to hear how
are you going to fix what's wrong in
this country because that's what people
are starving to hear look you know they
can say whatever they say you know I
believe the southern border I mean look
you got to be in you got to be
on drugs not to realize what's going on
he's bringing all these people in here
he's going to hope it's some way he
gives them a path to citizenship so they
can vote or at least vote and they want
to be in power forever that's it that's
it that's the total plan they're not
humanitarians they don't care about
these people coming in that's got to be
the plan and for people not to see that
I don't get it I really don't Patrick so
you know Trump DeSantis
okay if Trump were back in office his
policies would be good he would I think
he would do the right thing again I
really believe that he cares about this
country I mean that's what I see in him
aside from all the other clutter that's
around him he cares about this country
but I don't know if we can take that
again I don't know if we can take him in
office again so you would rather see the
santis over Trump you know because I
think DeSantis his policies will be just
as good he'll do the right thing and
maybe less stuff that we have to listen
to unless the right I mean the left goes
after him in the same way I don't know
he doesn't have that kind of baggage it
seems that it that he can be attacked
like Trump was
but I think Michael brings up a really
good point uh about maybe the difference
between Trump and DeSantis you know A
wise man once said choose your enemies
wisely all right that would be a great
book title yeah be a great book title
coming out soon
um and I think Trump's problem was I
think Michael's absolutely right he was
attacked viciously by the left and some
of it was warranted some of it was
unwarranted some of it was Trump
drainsman syndrome
the problem with Trump is everyone was
his enemy like you know how they say
don't punch down punch up right he would
pick a fight with everybody like no
matter what he would punch him 10 times
harder and 99 of the time he should not
even respond to some of these Twitter
folks or just any just media Outlet
anything just don't even give him the
time of day
but he would and he would engage in
these little battles with people that
were completely beneath him whereas
DeSantis uh maybe he had a a little
preview of that book that that might be
coming out soon and he's choosing his
enemies very wisely whether it's Disney
whether it's the woke Florida is where
woke comes to die whether it's the
abortion issue he's picking and choosing
his battles but I love this one response
when Trump was banging on him and
somebody said what do you think about
Trump anger he says I'm not a candidate
right that was it
but just perfect correct he's he's
living to the fullest what we're talking
about right now he's like he knows it
doesn't make sense at this point no to
start engaging in a battle with Trump
yet at some point he's gonna probably
have to step up to the podium to do that
if he wants you well hopefully he'll do
it intelligently and he won't get into
the the real dirt the way Trump does I
mean that's that's not good for anybody
it wears you out it wears you was that
your biggest problem with Trump not the
policies it was just the personality and
then going down that rabbit hole of of
nonsensical stuff I I cannot believe
some of the you know criticisms that
people have about Trump and I tell him
listen you know in a way president it is
a personality contest you want to see
somebody that's charismatic and has a
personality but it's really about his
policies and how he deals with America
and I always tell it's not personal I'm
not going to have you know Trump go out
with my daughter I don't invite him over
for dinner but his policies were good
for America you know so what else are
you looking at what do you care about
what he did in his personal life I mean
yeah you know now I mean you know the
CNN you know some of the the uh
criticism of him while he's you know
he's his sexual abuser and he's this he
that how could you have him on
television well he's running for
president what do you mean you know
that's when you realize is CNN really a
news organization anymore
because the people within CNN are
knocking them meanwhile they had the
highest ratings they had in how long why
wouldn't you put them on the air you
know who's calling Trump's Camp right
now MSNBC saying hey then NBC from the
top is saying you guys better not do
this this is not worth it don't give
them the eyeballs MSM is like we
need some writers
absolutely all says well and then and
then you know who's probably going to
end up being last it's going to be fox
fox is going to be end up being less on
a Town Hall he's going to do a town hall
with everybody look how he works look
how he works these are the things that
you have to give credit to Fox doesn't
want to do a town hall he says no
problem who's your number one enemy CNN
I'm gonna go to a town hall with them
then MSNBC then you're going to call me
and say wow we're not doing a tunnel
because all the fox viewers are going to
ask you how come you're not doing a
tunnel you're fans your viewers who pay
the money are gonna force you to do a
town hall and it's going to be on my
term so I'll be patient in the next six
months you'll host a town hall for me
except it's going to be on my terms this
is the kind of stuff that
you want a guy like that that's
negotiating with Putin with G with
zelinski with this with that you want
you want that you don't want somebody
that's going and saying whose ice cream
is better Russia or China you know you
want somebody that's wanting to really
figure out ways to use power plays
the world you're in one of the things uh
uh when the first time you and I Satan
you had written a book and uh make you
an offer I'll make you know if you can't
read first of all it's every businessman
we're not here to promote his book trust
me that's not the reason for why it's
here this is just a thing if you're if
you run a business and you're running a
company just on the side put the link
below do yourself a favor go buy this
book I think after the when I we talked
about it we saw like 100 000 copies I
don't know what happened put the link
below I'm telling you if you're in
business go read this book I think it's
only 140 Pages 150 Pages if you go to
the bottom how many pages is it it's the
most use it's the best use 155 Pages
read do yourself a favor
in the business World take all the stuff
that you guys did illegally though all
the other stuff take the murder take
that out
man that's you know you know there's a
lot of the stuff that you you talk about
in this book is stuff that you got to
have if you're going to run for office
the gamesmanship that the enemy is going
to use against you the manipulation the
opponent is going to use against you how
do you deal with that how do you manage
that how do you work with that how do
you still go out and get a deal how do
you negotiate how do you not go in a
room without any kind of Leverage to
negotiate and still find a leverage how
do you go and when you have all the
leverage in the world and you can
destroy the person and figure out a way
to make them an ally how do you there's
so many different things there to use
um I think that's the part that you
can't teach somebody to do and it seems
like he's got a bit of it so if if he
does get reelected man it's going to be
well America is going to lose their
minds if he gets reelected so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]